[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAYTON WILKINSON: Hello.
My name's Clayton Wilkinson.
I work in developer relations
with games and Daydream.
And one of the
things I remember,
growing up as a child, was going
to the Air and Space Museum.
And they'd just opened
up a new movie theater,
and they were playing this
movie called "The Fly."
And it was a small
theater, really steep.
But when the balloon took off
and they went over this cliff,
then the whole screen
opened up into IMAX,
and I was just blown away.
And what really
excites me now is
I can take these
types of experiences
and make them a Daydream and
bring them to other people.
So I want to go over
a few things here
that will help you
make your own Daydream
applications for video.
So, we're going to walk
through three things.
The first one will be
some design considerations
with Daydream.
It's a little different
than a normal mobile app.
The second one, we'll go over
video quality and what makes
video good what makes it bad.
And finally, Unity, which
is a really great tool
for making Daydream apps.
And then also some components
we've made to really jumpstart
your application development.
So, VR is a little
bit different.
You've probably heard some
of these things before.
It's designed to bring a
new reality to people--
to give them a new experience.
The sessions are a
little bit longer.
You've got 40 minutes--
maybe longer--
of sitting in a relaxed spot.
You're not walking around.
You're not sitting
in a conference.
You're really focused
on the application.
So you've got to take
that into account.
And if you think about
the range of motion,
you have about 70
degrees to work with.
It's about 30 degrees from
either side, comfortably.
If you really want the user--
they can stretch, maybe
rotate their shoulders--
and they can see 80 degrees
either side pretty comfortably,
but it's still a stretch.
So we want to keep the main
focus of the application really
there in the front,
in that 70 degrees.
And in terms of
distance, you really
want to be somewhere
between half a meter
and 20 meters away.
That's kind of the virtual
distance you want to work with.
Anything that's up
close, you really
end up straining your eyes--
maybe crossing your eyes--
to try to focus on that.
And far away, it really
turns into something flat.
There's not a lot
of depth perception.
And speaking of
depth perception,
you really want to
have some texture
and shadow in your environment.
So you can see here,
before the texture was
added to these squares, they
just kind of looked like blobs.
But now that we've
added a little texture
and a little shadow, you can see
that there's really three boxes
and circles moving around them.
So, all these
mechanics are good.
But you really need to
think about the environment
that you're in.
So, you want to
convey some presence.
You want to take them somewhere.
And if you look
at this screen, it
would be a great screen for
maybe a web page or something.
It's a little plain.
But it really doesn't
convey anything.
And something I see a
lot of-- and I do a lot
of in my prototypes--
we're all guilty of it-- is
kind of these void spaces.
So, you make the space and
then an infinite plane.
And you put your content
in it and throw it there.
And it's fast.
It renders very quickly.
It gives you that
sense of VR-ness.
But it really doesn't
take you anywhere.
It's not very memorable.
So you really miss
this opportunity
to make something memorable
in your application.
So if you look at the
Daydream home screen,
it does a really
good job of this.
It's got some
environment that you
can look at-- things to
focus on-- you kind of follow
that water into the
center of the screen.
And then you have your content.
So, this is really to focus
your attention on the content.
Then you can do
something even crazy,
like this example here where
we've taken the same content
but we've kind of integrated
it into the environment.
So, you've got the
rock there that is
framing the menu at the bottom.
Then you've got this sunlight
coming through the trees that's
kind of a spotlight
on your content
to really focus the eyes there.
The challenge here,
though, is this really
is hard to do if you're going
to move the content at all.
So, you don't want to
move the menu back,
for example, into the rock or
you've got to move the rock.
And it gets really complex.
So this is kind of
the very extreme case.
If you can do this,
fantastic, but you normally
end up with some compromises.
So, you can make a great
environment and great presence
of your app.
But you really need
to have great video
to have a great video app.
And the first thing when we
talk about quality of video
is resolution.
So this is the number
of pixels or the number
of samples in the frame
that we're looking at.
And as you can see, there's a
wide range from the very low
definition-- so maybe these
are things that show up
on television or on
little game devices--
all the way up to 4K, which
is kind of the cutting
edge of what you can find
both on mobile devices
and televisions today.
And these are the kind of
proportional relationships
that's not to scale, but
relative to each other
they're scaled.
And there's a lot more bits to
move as you get into the higher
resolutions.
And you've got to
think about that,
because it's going
to take more CPU.
It's going to take more time,
more bandwidth if you're
streaming, and you have
to be aware of that.
So you want to balance
your resolution
to the quality of the
content that you're sending.
Now when we talk
about resolution,
usually you hear numbers
like 1080p or 720i.
And this is what those
p's and i's mean.
So you've got progressive.
Means that every
single line is shown.
And you've get a
complete picture.
Where interlaced is
every other line.
And this allows a trick
that-- in a movie,
where half the lines are
sent the first frame.
In the subsequent frame,
the second half is sent.
So you can have a
very large resolution
and only use half
the bits every frame.
So this gives you an
advantage of bit rate.
The price of it is the
quality of the video.
It can be a little bit softer.
Maybe motion is blurry.
So you want to be
aware, if you're
going to use an
interlaced video,
that you've got slow motion
and kind of a soft picture.
Also, with the capturing of the
video, you've got aspect ratio.
And aspect ratio is that--
the ratio of the width
to the height of the screen.
And you want to make sure that,
when you present the video back
to the user, you're
aware of the aspect
ratio it was captured with.
If not, you'll see what happens.
Like here, we've
got a four by three,
which is kind of a
standard definition
ratio shown on an HD screen.
And so it stretches it out,
and it looks kind of weird.
Also in VR, we have the
opportunity to do 360 degrees.
So this is fantastic.
You can take a picture-- and
I've seen some people holding
them up in the cameras and
walking around outside also--
and you get these spherical
views of the world.
So here's one I took on top
of our San Francisco office
one day.
And you can kind of see,
the middle part of it
looks pretty normal.
But as you get to the top
and bottom of the image,
it gets really stretched out.
And so you have to be
aware of what projection
was used by the
camera so that you
can show the same projection
when you render it.
So the most common one is called
the equirectangular projection.
And this is where it kind
of unfolds the sphere
into a rectangle, and
stretching the top
of the sphere along the top of
the rectangle and the bottom.
So the poles get very
distorted and the middle part
is very clear.
And so you can see,
once I put it back
on the inside of the sphere,
the distortion goes away
and you can see the Bay
Bridge very clearly.
You can also do stereo vision.
So, you've all
been to 3-D movies
where they do polarized views.
Well, you can also do
stereo projections in VR
where you've got two
separate images for each eye.
Maybe the left side is
on top of the right eye,
like in this example.
And here, each of
them are slightly
different-- slightly
offset-- so when
you show them side by
side, your eyes see
the difference in
depth perception
and it looks stereoscopic.
So, all of this was about the
dimensions and the resolution
aspect ratios of a single frame.
But when you look at a movie,
it's made up of lots of frames.
And that's called the
frame rate, of course.
And so here are
all the frame rates
that you'll probably
ever encounter.
And as you can see,
it's a long list.
And there's no right frame
rate or wrong frame rate.
It mostly has to do
with the capturing.
So at the bottom, it's
typically like a standard movie
would be--
24 frames per second,
something like that.
In television, it tends
to be around 29.97,
or 30 if you're in Europe.
And then specialized HD
cameras, digital cameras,
tend to get up into
the higher frame rates.
And this is important
to understand
when you're playing back.
Because if you're
playing it back
too slowly-- if you've
captured a very fast frame rate
and you're playing it
slowly, it might look jerky
because you're skipping frames.
And alternatively, if
you've got a low capture,
you're never going to
be able to speed it
up faster than that
capture rate and have
any appreciable
improvement in quality.
So now that we've got
multiple frames coming
at us, different
resolutions, we want
to be able to do
things with that.
We need to read it, process
it, decode it, put it
on the screen.
Maybe we're downloading
it from a server.
And so we talk about bit rate.
And this is where the--
they call them
encoders or codecs--
come into play.
So a very common one
is the h.263 encoder.
And that's found on
almost every device now.
And they're usually
implemented in hardware.
The h.265 encoder
is coming, and it
will be on more modern devices
and it's much more efficient
at this compression.
So you can see--
these are the recommended
data rates for h.264
for the different resolutions.
And so you can imagine trying
to push 40 megabits a second
over a crowded
Wi-Fi connection--
it might be a
little challenging.
So you may have
to scale it down,
if that's your
environment, or you
may need to be aware of that
and not do a lot of processing
around the video if you have
special effects and things
like that.
So, let's talk about Daydream.
If you look at the Android
standard specification,
this is what we say to vendors--
that if you want to be Daydream
ready, these are the things
you need to support
in your device.
And so h.264, of
course, is there at 4K.
So the maximum resolution
we really can get
is 4K at 30 frames
per second with 40
megabits per second transfer.
So this allows them to
measure how much CPU
is needed to actually
get the video decoded
and on the screen.
And then we also ask for 265.
So, it's so much more
efficient that you
should be able to get the
1080p at the same frame rate,
but a quarter of the data rate
because 265 is that much more
efficient.
So equivalently
we're saying, here
you can run four
1080p video streams
at the same time
on the same device
if you're using h.265 encoding.
And you can see, the minimum
resolution that we want
is that 1080p.
But ideally, you've
got a higher resolution
so you can get a much
nicer and richer view.
So, when we talk about VR
It's a little different
than just watching a
movie or a YouTube stream
on your device in your hand.
Since you're holding
it up in the viewer
and you're looking at it
with, essentially, magnifying
glasses, you want to be able
to have a really high quality
image so you're not
really distracted
by little imperfections in the
video and things like that.
So, the minimum we recommend
for a monoscopic video--
so where both eyes are
seeing the exact same image--
is there.
The 1080p, 30 frames per second
again, and about 16 megabits
per second.
So that's pretty comfortable.
It's pretty easy to get that.
But it gives you
a very nice image.
And then if you're doing
360 or stereoscopic,
there's really double the
amount of information you need.
So, 360 degree with that
equirectangular projection--
the majority of the
bits are not seen
by the user at any one time.
They're behind you
or off to the sides.
So, we want to
double the resolution
and really get up there to the
4K size, so that way half of it
is shown in the eyes
and it looks very good.
And you can see the difference,
really, of bit rate.
So, it only went
to 24 not to 32,
if there's any math
wizzes out there.
And that's because
of this compression.
So, the encoder-- as
it's compressing--
will find repeating
sections of the frames.
As you get larger, it's
all going to compress
more effectively.
So now, we've got a bit rate.
We've got a file, like an
MPEG4 file or something.
And we need to do
something with it.
We need to get it
onto the device
so we can actually show it.
There's a couple
different ways to do that.
The first way, of course,
is to download it.
You could package it up into an
auxiliary file-- an OBB file--
and download it
off the Play Store.
Or you could put it on your own
server and download it there.
So maybe you've got
sports highlights
every week, or current
events in the news,
and it just gets downloaded and
then they can play it offline.
So this is great because if
you don't have connectivity all
the time-- your user doesn't--
they can download it
and then play it back
whenever they want to.
They don't need to be
connected to the internet.
You're also easy to
encode these because you
don't have to worry about
multiple resolutions
and multiple data rates,
like if you were streaming.
And you can have really
easy delivery, like I said.
The downside is, you've got
to figure out what to send.
So, you need to do
some catalog management
and curate your list a
little bit more closely.
You also need to have
a way to delete files
that you're not using anymore.
So after a year, you don't want
to fill up the user's device.
On the streaming side-- we're
all pretty familiar with this--
you know, YouTube streams.
There's a couple other
companies out there that stream.
And the great thing about it
is there's tons of content.
You can have an internet
full of content,
and just be able to select
it and then play it back.
The user's not
expected to download
anything they're not using.
So they like it.
It's really-- eat the
bandwidth as you use it
type of model, which is great.
And everyone seems to
understand how to use it.
So they know how to get on, log
on, and start streaming video
pretty easily.
The downside is this
encoding problem.
So as you saw--
especially with larger,
high quality videos--
the speed creates
a bit rate problem.
And to be guaranteed a high
bandwidth connection on Wi-Fi
sometimes can be challenging.
So what you want to do is
encode at multiple bit rates.
So you usually do that
by different resolutions.
So you start with the 4K
stream for your best quality,
and you go down to a
2K and maybe 1080p.
And from there, you
use a server that's
using something like the
dash or the HLS protocol
to switch between these
different streams seamlessly.
So the user may see a little
degrading of the quality.
It gets a little fuzzy
for maybe a second.
And then it will jump back up
as network conditions improve.
So now, we've got all this
video and we've figured out
how we're going to get
it there and all of that.
We'll go ahead and look
a little bit at Unity.
And not everyone's seen Unity.
So the first thing
I wanted to do
was just give a quick
tour of the Unity editor
so as we talk about things,
you'll kind of understand.
You lay out a 3DC here with
the hierarchy on the left.
And like, for example,
here is the camera
and you can see what
the camera sees.
And you can set some properties
in this Property Inspector
over here on the right.
And in order to make
it Daydream capable,
you have to turn
on the VR support.
So you do that here on
the Android side by just
checking this
little box and then
selecting Daydream out of this.
One of the important
things to remember
is, when you're watching videos
it's going to be a long time.
It's not just going to
be 30 or 40 minutes.
It might be an
hour or two hours.
So you really want to make sure
that that sustained performance
mode is checked.
So now, you've got a scene.
You can add simple models to it.
So here, built into Unity,
you can add cubes and planes
and triangles and cylinders.
And here's one.
You can move them around.
More complex things you would
build in a modeling tool,
and you can import them.
And we can also change
behaviors of the cubes.
So here we can add
physical things to it.
We can call a
component a rigid body,
for example, which adds
mass and it interplays
with the physics system.
We can turn off the gravity
in VR mode, of course.
And then we can
add custom scripts.
And this is where the
application building
comes in that will add
custom behaviors that you
script in C Sharp.
So here, we can make one called
Spin that will spin the cube.
And you just-- here, when
the application starts,
you would just grab
that rigid body
and then call Add
Torque to this.
And it will start
spinning the object here.
That's pretty exciting.
So here, to make
it more exciting we
would take one of these 3D
models that we've built.
So an environment, for example.
And here is-- whoops.
One too many clicks.
So we can add these
prefabricated components.
So these were made outside or in
a different instance of Unity.
This particular one was a
room we made, and just kind of
modeled some shapes on it
to give it a little bit
different feel.
And so, it gives it a
completely different feel.
It's the exact same
program we just ran.
And so you can
see the real power
of getting that environment set.
So here's kind of a block
diagram of everything
that's involved
in that Unity app.
So we've got Unity
itself there, which
contains the scene, the 3D
models, the C Sharp script
that you would write.
We add to it also the
Google VR SDK, the GVR SDK,
which you can download
from developers.google.com
or from GitHub.
And then part of this
is a video plugin
that connects the exoplayer
plugin-- which, there
was a talk yesterday about it.
You could see it on YouTube
if you didn't see it
and you're interested.
There's also some
code labs about it.
But this really wraps the
media services and Android
into something that's
very digestible
and customizable and
simple to work with.
And then it also
handles communicating
with the VR services that
are part of Android operating
system.
And these systems that
are part of Android
handle these things
for you so you
don't have to handle them
in your application code,
or as you're drawing in Unity.
Async reprojection
is this concept
of being able to turn
your head very fast.
And instead of trying to draw
a continuous stream as you're
turning your head,
async reprojection
can detect your head
motion and then draw
the existing image
in the right place
so, as you turn your
head to the right,
it kind of moves
to the left and you
don't get that nauseous
feeling like nothing's moving.
It also handles lens distortion.
So again, those
lenses in Daydream
are essentially spherical
magnifying glasses.
And we want to present
to that a distorted image
so when it goes through the
lens it will be corrected.
And this handles adding that
distortion automatically
so you don't have
to do it every time.
There's also support
for spatial audio.
So this allows you to put
sounds in your 3-D model.
And sounds will emanate
from behind you,
and as you turn around you'll
be looking at the sound.
And your ears and your eyes
will continue to be in sync
and build that illusion of
being in a different place.
And of course,
there's the mechanics
of head tracking
and the controller.
Exoplayer.
This is a super simple model.
And if you need to
know more about it,
I would definitely
point you back
to YouTube for yesterdays
talk, and the code lab
that you can do in the code lab
area for today and tomorrow.
And what this does is it
gives you a capability
to customize each step in this
process of playing the video.
So if you think about
a video itself--
like maybe an MPEG4 or
a stream on a server,
there's a data source.
And that data source can be in
a variety of different formats.
And then that needs to be
extracted into the decoder.
And so the decoder is going
to take those bits that you
got off the file or
off the internet,
and it's going to decompress
them into a video stream,
audio streams, maybe
closed captioning, and then
feed that to the
exoplayer class itself.
Now in the class
itself, it's going
to handle buffering
because it's not
going to be able to decode
as fast as it's playing back.
So we usually do a
little bit ahead of time,
and that way there's
plenty of data
to consume as we're rendering.
And then under
Application Control
there's the track selector.
And the track
selector says you want
to show this video
and this audio.
Maybe you have
multiple audio streams
for different
languages, or maybe you
have a stereo and
mono and you want
to have different
selections for those,
or different resolutions,
and you can select the tracks
and show those
through the renderers.
And the renderers are the thing
that actually draw or render
sound.
So there's a lot of
moving parts to this,
and it can be kind
of overwhelming
as we found as we started
building some of these samples
for Daydream.
So we decided to
bundle them together
into a media app template.
And this template will be
available on GitHub shortly.
I don't think it's there today,
but it should be very soon.
And this gives you the
Unity building blocks,
these prefab models
and scripts that
will allow you to really
jumpstart your application
and you can focus on delivering
a great experience to the user
rather than how to decode video.
So the first thing
we've added to it
is a selection system with
breadcrumb navigation.
So you've got a
series of folders,
and you can make
your own categories
and put videos in them.
And then you can navigate
up and down the hierarchy.
Another thing we did
was add this capability
of not only showing the video,
but sampling it and creating
a light source in Unity
that's representative
of the video frame that's
being shown at that time.
So you get this nice
admissive effect
from the video, like
I'm low from the screen
or the television
or whatever it is.
And it adds really a sense of
warmth and being to the screen.
It feels like it's really there.
We also found that
not everyone likes
to sit in the front row
at a movie theater--
or in the back row.
So we allow zooming of it.
And you can see this also in
the YouTube Daydream app, where
it allows you to actually move
the screen in and out to where
it's at a comfortable
position for you to view.
And it makes a really
big difference.
When you're trying to sit there
and watch a movie for an hour,
you want to be
comfortable and relaxed.
And being comfortable
and relaxed
doesn't always mean being level.
So Daydream always
wants the horizon
to be level and straight ahead.
And this allows you
to tilt the screen.
So if you're leaning
back in your chair
or you're lying on your bed,
you can move the screen up
and you don't have
to crane your neck
to look down at the screen.
So again, this is
another comfort thing.
And also, 360 repositioning.
So I don't know
how many of you've
tried to look at a 360 video
or even image in Daydream,
but it seems like--
at least for me, always--
I pick it up and the main thing
I'm supposed to be looking at
is over there.
And so I end up looking around.
And it's like, oh.
There it is.
Now I can look at it.
So this allows you to pick
it up and move it back
into your center, so you can
be comfortably seated again
and the subject is
right in front of you.
And of course,
playback controls.
So you can spend a lot of
time making playback controls.
We decided just to make some for
you and save you the headache.
Now, we do a pretty good
job of looking at the stream
when we're playing it back
and trying to determine
what format it's in.
So, make sure we get
the projection right.
Aspect ratio can be adjusted.
If it's stereoscopic,
is it side by side eyes?
Is it top and bottom eyes?
But sometimes we don't
choose right or maybe
you just want to explore
and try different things.
So you can do that here
by changing the projection
manually as well.
So, just to kind
of summarize what's
in this media app template--
it's really all
these prefabs here
that you can pull into
your own projects,
customize, and integrate
into your application.
You've got the
breadcrumb in the title.
You can tilt and zoom the
screen, which is great,
and the playback controls.
And of course, that
emissive lighting,
which is really tricky
to get sometimes.
To kind of wrap everything up--
I know we've covered everything.
And I just want to
have one checklist
to cover these things.
And you really want to keep
the user comfort first at hand.
Having them sit in
a comfortable place
and not have to move
their shoulders around
or look up and down is going to
be make your app that much more
enjoyable.
And they'll go back and
play it again and again.
You want to take the opportunity
to make a destination,
a place that they can go.
So when they think
about it, they'll
go, oh, yeah, I want to watch
this video in the sports arena
or whatever environment
you decide to make.
And it gives them
something else to remember
rather than that empty space.
You want to spend some time
looking at your encoding
as well, to make sure that
you're delivering the best
quality video you
can possibly get
in the constraints
of the application
you're really targeting.
If you're targeting
off line people,
you want to target
downloading those things
and having good encoding.
If you're targeting
streaming people,
then you have to encode
in these other bit rates
to make sure that
everything can be switched
depending on network quality.
And you really want
to match as best
you can what
information was used
when they captured the video.
So the aspect ratio--
you don't want to
try to recalculate
aspect ratio on the fly.
Or if it's in the
equirectangular projection,
you want to make sure
that your sphere is pretty
close to the sphere they use.
And that way, your
images look just as great
as they were when
they were captured.
And finally, delight your users.
I mean, that's why we're here.
We love to make great apps.
And so make whatever
you do really enjoyable
and think about how
they're going to use it--
and would you use it
over and over again?
Because if it's a
one time deal, great.
That's fine.
But you really want
something that they'll use
over and over and over again.
So here are some
links to get things.
Definitely the
Daydream overview site
is a good starting point,
where there's many more
links to different samples.
And these GitHub repos.
And again, exoplayer is
very configurable and very,
very powerful.
I would suggest checking
out their site as well,
as well as code labs,
and maybe they're talk.
So, thanks for your
attention today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]